[Musique]
aumale annoncé ma vie la chose qu'ils
veulent quand ils veulent la perf et
voudrait simplement je veux être heureux
d'une manière très simple pour eux le
bonheur c'est tout ce que enfin leur
leur esprit complètement imprégné de
tout de toutes les images de tout le
vocabulaire du bonheur qui n'est pas
leur vocabulaire
quel afin qu'ils aient leur vocabulaire
mais qui leur est donnée par l'est par
les journaux par par l'express par heure
par les magasins nous vivons dans un
monde qui est beau que nous parle d'une
manière très forte
la beauté d'une ouverture d'un meuble
nous sentons tout de suite qu'elle
contient beaucoup plus de choses que la
simple beauté
il nous semble qu'elle détient une sorte
de secret qu'elle nous offre un
véritable art de vivre que tout ce qui
nous est donné à voir c'est beaucoup
plus de choses que la beauté c'est de
l'argent c'est du confort du bonheur
c'est presque une certaine forme idéale
les voitures luisantes les meubles
étincelant des espaces immenses et
claire avec les moquettes le monde dans
lequel nous vivons le monde que nous
rencontrons chaque fois que nous sortons
dans la rue chaque fois que nous entrons
dans les magasins est un monde riche
fascinant et beau l'ennui c'est que nous
pouvons voir nous n'avons pas le droit
de toucher parce qu'en fait nous ne
vivons pas l'enseignement
nous ne conduisons pas ces voitures ne
mangeons pas du foie gras du homard nos
repas ne vivons pas dans les espaces
clairs couvert de moquette
cette différence face ce qui cette
différence entre ce que nous pouvons
rêver ce que nous donne à rêver
ce que nous nous sommes donnés comme
rêve et la réalité beaucoup plus
mesquine et rétréci de notre vie c'est à
dire nos appartement encombré nous
vaisselle trajets en métro
c'est cette différence est à la base de
ce que veut et de ce que cherche le
publicité dans la société que l'on
appelle société de consommation et
sociale est consommé et tout nous pousse
à consommer mais les déceptions les
frustrations qui accompagne cette quête
du beau
l'air que nous avons confondu trop vite
avec le confort avec la richesse cette
déception constituent une part très
importante la publicité des étalages de
vitrine une certaine manière nous
rendent fous nous saoulent toutes ces
choses ne sont là que pour entretenir
une espèce de frénésie de vertige
hypnose
[Musique]